we begin this half-hour with the
continuing fallout from Major League
Baseball's science dealing scandal the
controversy has already cost three major
league baseball managers and a general
manager their jobs it is also called
into question the legitimacy of the
Houston Astros 2017 World Series title
while a scandal has rocked baseball to
the core it turns out cheating is as old
as sport itself Major League Baseball
says the Houston Astros went high-tech
to gain an unfair advantage on their way
to the World Series title in 2017 the
team used a centerfield camera to decode
opposing catcher's signals to pitchers
and transmit them live into the dugout
from there players would bang on a trash
can to tell batters what kind of pitch
to expect
investigators also concluded information
was sent to phones or watches of team
members in the dugout as far as baseball
is concerned I happen to think this is
the biggest scandal we've seen Fran Zim
Nick is the author of crooked a history
of cheating in sports steroids and peds
were huge but that was examples of
individual players doing things
themselves this is a this is basically a
team working together to cheat baseball
has a long history of bad behavior from
rampant PE D use Pete Rose betting on
games the 1919 Black Sox scandal all the
way down to players tossing spit balls
and using corked bats even one of the
sports signature moments was later
marred by scandal
[Applause]
when it was revealed Bobby Thompson of
the New York Giants hit the shot heard
round the world after coach Herrmann
Frank's allegedly relayed and illegally
stolen sign roots of the Astro scheme
can even be found as far back as 1900s
carried out by a Philadelphia Phillies
backup catcher named Morgan Murphy
they put a box underneath the third-base
coaching box and it was charged so that
there was a line that went from that box
all the way underground in back of the
outfield fence where Morgan Murphy had a
hole in the fence with a little
telescope and he was stealing signs and
he would basically shock the third-base
coach and it's not just baseball
examples of unfair play have been
uncovered in the ancient Olympics pro
football cycling college basketball even
the Boston Marathon when Rosie Ruiz won
the race after sneaking onto the course
about a mile from the finish line people
get a cheaters high when they outsmart a
system Maurice Schweitzer researches
deception and cheating for Penn's
Wharton School of Business he blames the
astros scandal and other episodes of
cheating on an obsession with winning
becomes the key objective other things
become secondary and the accolades
people get used to it they value winning
and they're gonna cut corners in in
other ways but while cheaters have been
found out from biblical times all the
way up to the Super Bowl era
zim Nick believes they haven't learned
their lesson it seems to me that instead
of saying that cheaters never prosper we
should be saying that cheaters often
prosper and that's the big question for
a lot of people with this World Series
title and wanting Major League Baseball
to put an asterisks or do something
about it because they say but they still
won the World Series and you're saying
later you're gonna get punished but you
still won and this one this case you had
three three managers dismissed right a
general manager fired and owner fined
five million dollars I get all that
but if it's a player-driven scandal if
this was a VM immunity in order to tell
us what happened and none of you will be
punished was what Major League Baseball
did because they wanted to get to the
bottom of it that's why they were not
punished
you